IN JUNE.
HARRIS.
>> Harris: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MORE DEMOCRATIC LEADERS ARE
PEELING BACK COVID MANDATES.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS LIFTING
ITS OUTDOOR MASK MANDATE TODAY.
GOOD THING AFTER THE RAMS WIN
WHICH WAS FABULOUS, BY THE WAY,
THE GAME IN TOTAL WAS GREAT BUT
ALL THE MAYOR HOLDING HIS
BREATH THE HOLD TIME BECAUSE HE
DIDN'T HAVE ON A MASK.
OUTDOORS AND SAFE FOR THEM NOW.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS ONE
OF FOUR BLUE STATES WHICH NO
LONGER HAVE INDOOR MASK
MANDATES BUT ARE KEEPING THE
SCHOOLS MASKED UP.
WHILE FIVE OTHER DEMOCRATIC-LED
STATES HAVE OPTED TO LET
CHILDREN COME TO SCHOOL WITHOUT
WEARING MASKS.
IT'S THE CHOICE OF THE PARENTS.
DESPITE A LOT OF CRITICISM THAT
THESE DECISIONS ARE POLITICAL
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI WEIGHED IN.
>> DO YOU THINK THE LOCAL
POLITICS WHEN IT COMES TO THESE
KIND OF MANDATES ARE OVERRIDING
THE SCIENCE OR LARGELY NO?
>> WELL, I WOULDN'T SAY IT'S
THE POLITICS.
I THINK IT'S THE DIFFERENT
EVALUATION OF WHAT'S RIGHT FOR
A PARTICULAR COMMUNITY.
WE USE THE WORD POLITICS I'M
NOT SO SURE IT'S THAT.
I JUST THINK AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
THERE IS A STRONG FEELING OF
NEEDING TO GET BACK TO
NORMALITY.
>> Harris: JIMMY FAILLA IS HOST
OF FOX ACROSS AMERICA ON FOX
NEWS RADIO.
DR. FAUCI COULD HAVE JUST SAID
POLITICS NOT MY LANE.
HE NEVER SAYS THAT.
>> IT IS HIS LANE.
WE SHOULD REPLACE FAUCI WITH
SOMETHING AMERICANS TRUST MORE
LIKE THE SUSHI AT A GAS STATION.
NOBODY TAKES THIS GUY
SERIOUSLY, HARRIS.
>> Harris: IT CAN BE DELICIOUS.
>> BUT YOU LOOK AT POLLING
THAT'S 31% OF AMERICANS DON'T
TAKE HIS HEALTH INITIATIVE
SERIOUSLY.
IF YOU ARE RUNNING AN NFL TEAM
AND 69% OF PLAYERS THAT
WOULDN'T RUN THE PLAY YOU WON'T
WIN THE GAME.
FAUCI LOST THE LOCKER ROOM AND
HAS TO GO.
MASK MANDATES DEMOCRATIC
LEADERS ARE JUMPING INTO
POLITICAL LIFE BOATS.
THE COVID REGIME IS SINKING AND
THEY WANT TO GET OFF.
>> Harris: A GOOD THING FOR THE
COMMUNITIES.
WHAT I DON'T UNDERSTAND IS THE
SCIENCE POINTS TO TAKING THE
MASK OFF THE CHILDREN FIRST
JUST BECAUSE OF THE PERCENTAGE
OF THEM WHO HAVE ALREADY HAD IT
AND THE PERCENTAGE OF THEM WHO
DON'T SUFFER MIGHTILY FROM IT
WHEN THEY GET IT PARTICULARLY
WITH OMICRON.
LETTING THEM CHOOSE THINGS LIKE
MENTAL HEALTH AND THOSE ISSUES
FIRST.
AND THEN FEATHERING IN THE
ADULTS.
>> THAT'S WHAT INFURIATING.
THEY WOULD ACCUSE US OF BEING
CAVALIER WITH CHILDREN'S HEALTH
TO UNMASK THEM BUT MASKING THEM
IS.
TO THE POINTS YOU JUST MADE THE
CDC FLAT OUT TELLS US A CLOTH
MASK DOESN'T WORK AGAINST
OMICRON.
FULL STOP.
THE MASK COMES OFF.
MASKING KIDS IS CHILD ABUSE AND
SICKENING TO ME.
>> Harris: MOST PEOPLE WILL
NEVER PUT THEIR CHILD IN AN N95.
THE ONES THAT LEAVE ALL THE
DIVOTS IN YOUR FACE.
THEY ARE SAYING THOSE ARE THE
ONES THAT REALLY WORK.
HAVE YOU HAD ONE SHOW UP AT
YOUR HOUSE YET?
THEY SAY THEY ARE SENDING FIVE.
>> THEY ARE COMING FROM CHINA.
A SHIPPING DELAY.
IT DRIVES ME CRAZY.
WITHOUT ANY DATA TO SUPPORT IT
KIDS ARE SITTING IN THE
CLASSROOM WITH A MASK ON.
THIS IS TRUE.
DO YOU REMEMBER THE MOTLEY CRUE
SONG SMOKING IN THE BOYS' ROOM.
NOW THEY GO TO THE BATHROOM TO
TAKE OFF THEIR MASKS.
>> Harris: LINCOLN IS THIS
BEAUTIFUL BABY.
>> HE IS A GOOD KID.
LINCOLN IS CONTROVERSIAL NOW.
WE HAVE TO GO BY HIS MIDDLE
NAME NOW.
>> Harris: PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
SHARING AN ANECDOTE FROM HIS
TIME IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
>> President Biden: GOT A CALL
ONE NIGHT.
WOMAN SAID TO ME NOT OF THE
SAME PERSUASION WAS I WAS
POLITICALLY SAYING THERE WAS A
DEAD DOG IN THE MORNING.
SHE SAID I WANT HIM REMOVED NOW.
I PAY YOUR SALARY.
SO I WENT OVER.
[LAUGHTER]
I PICKED IT UP, SHE SAID I WANT
IT OUT OF MY FRONT YARD.
I PUT IT ON HER DOORSTEP.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Harris: JIMMIE.
>> IF IT WAS TRUE DEAD DOG
REMOVAL WOULD BE ONE THING HE
LOWERED THE COST OF.
WE DON'T THINK IT IS TRUE.
ONE OF THE OTHER MADE-UP
STORIES LIKE HE WAS A TRUCK
DRIVER OR KNEW THE GUY ON
AMTRAK.
THIS IS THE STUPIDEST THING.
>> Harris: I HOPE I'M NOT
BECOMING MORE OF A CYNIC BUT
THIS IS WHAT I THOUGHT AT FIRST.
I THOUGHT IS HE IS FLEXING
POLITICALLY SO HE CAN APPEAR TO
A BAD BOY TO THE REPUBLICANS?
LOOK WHAT I DID TO THE
REPUBLICAN CALLER IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE NIGHT.
I WENT TO HER HOUSE, WHICH IS
SO INAPPROPRIATE.
LIKE FOLLOWING KYRSTEN SINEMA
INTO THE BATHROOM BECAUSE YOU
DON'T AGREE WITH HER POLITICS.
>> I DON'T THINK HE IS THAT
STRATEGIC.
I ACTUALLY THINK HE JUST LIKES
DOGS IN GENERAL.
THEY JUST ADOPTED ANOTHER DOG.
HE LIKES HAVING SOMEONE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE THAT MAKES DEALS
UNDER THE TABLE BESIDES HUNTER.
IT MEANS A LOT TO HIM.
GOOD NIGHT, EVERYBODY.
>> Harris: WOW, OKAY.
THAT'S MY ONLY WOW THIS